I think you have to be a special kind of
crazy to do this voluntarily hey y'all
what's up I'm destiny and today I'm
gonna be training with the US Coast
Guard I have pretty much been active my
entire life unfortunately my senior year
I tore my ACL and I've just had a really
hard time getting back into my fitness
journey so I'm a little nervous I know
it'll be intense but I hope it'll be all
right growing up as a military child has
definitely prepared me for this moment
hi I'm fuchsia green digger and I'm a
lieutenant in the Coast Guard so four
months if you can I was a very thin
person I got the record only six
push-ups I have sense taking a deeper
love for working out because I enjoy the
way it makes me feel and it's a awesome
stress reliever hey Tanisha hey destiny
how are you I'm good I'm nervous how are
you excited for today hopefully you can
keep up you and me both are hoping that
so can you kind of walk me through what
is this butt-whipping about to get it's
gonna be mainly a conditioning workout
we'll do some push-ups we'll be some
lower body work we're gonna be working
the shoulders and the arms and of course
the core all right well I guess I'm
gonna get ready for this workout
okay
[Music]
this was intense for this to be the
intro level of what y'all do is wild I
think he did awesome for pushing through
you were amazing
every dare I enjoyed this because you
can do this at home like I didn't really
need much equipment what we did use is
literally just something you can find
around the house I wanna say thanks to
the US Coast Guard for all they do for
our country now it is time for me to go
indulge in the breakfast that I just
earned
[Music]